We'll do live on the ground coverage and reactions of the Hassan
dog collar controversy. Okay. What What are this? What are this?
What? What just got linked to me? What is this?
Hassan guest says his dog collar is too tight. Oh, >> now
it's mainstream. I love her. I think her collar is too tight.
>> Well, it's uh Are we
It's >> You have to You have to be able to get two fingers
and I couldn't even get one. I think you're choking her. He's
like
>> it's it just is a lot of neck meat. >> Hassan
guest says his dog collar is too tight. Is that all it is? This
is nothing. This is literally nothing. Like this could easily
be Sorry. The the collar thing I don't think that's
This isn't anything.
But listen, the other clip is something. No, no, no, no, no.
That is not the main clip, guys. That is not the main clip. This
might be the biggest LSF story of the year. Huge numbers and
only an hour old. Okay. Well, is it is it are we are we on Hassan
dog shock color gate 24/7 coverage? Are we on 24/7 coverage of
the Hassan dog color problem? Oh my god. Is it It's all of the
threads.
It's Wait, why is it both of these threads, dude? Is stale not
doing anything here anymore? That's funny.
M4 Hassan, people are being tortured and murdered on mass in
Gaza. Well, I mean, you just have to answer for the clips. We're
going to cover them. Vigilant stream. It's on the docket today.
We're going to cover them. Now, we have to unfortunately, we
are 247 Kaya Protection Squad. Okay.
Uh, hold on. See here. Let me let me update my Twitch title cuz
listen, we're going to farm. We're going to farm.
Who cares about this Destiny Pixie
Gate live 247 coverage.
Uh Passan [__] Ka abuse gate live 24/7 coverage.
Listen, we still don't know. I I'm not going to I'm not going
to keep this too close to the chest for too long, guys. But we
still don't know exactly
what happened here. Okay, we're still waiting. We're still waiting.
Let me take a look at the original clip and then we'll go through
some of these other clips as well. Okay, let's take a look. We'll
go through all the clips. We We just want to know that what the
truth is. Okay, more than anything, we just want Ka to be okay.
So, let's take a quick look. This is the original clip.
>> So, the original clip here and the accusation is going
to be that as Ka steps off of her bed,
looks over at his camera, sees she's getting off and shocks Ka.
yells at Kai to get back on the bed and then Kai gets shocked
by a shock collar. Now, I've not seen anything that suggests
Kai's got a shot caller yet, but you know, people haven't combed
through all the VODs. We'll see. We'll see. America's much more
violence.
Okay, it's the same reason as to why America Ka, please just
go. Just
So, listen.
Do we need to Jesus Christ? >> Do we need to break this
down more?
>> He looks He looks He sees Kai. Let me turn it up. >> Please
just >> He looks over. He's looking at >> [__]
go. >> He puts his hand down. Now, there's a couple different
things going on here. Okay. Puts his hand down. He's still looking
at her. >> Would you stop?
>> She barks. Now, I want you to listen cuz the big thing
for me
is that the big thing for me
He doesn't pause his chat. No, no, no, no. He doesn't pause his
chat. But the big thing for me is when you listen, it sounds
like he put something down. Did you hear that click? >> He
like puts something down. So, I don't know if he had a remote.
Right. I Now that's just That's just me. That could be his mouse.
Uh his mouse is over in his other hand, though. 100%. He's right-handed.
He's definitely got his I've seen him like move his m mouse hand
around. I'm almost positive here.
>> Jesus Christ. What are you doing? >> You're being
>> You know what? I I [__] up for you guys.
Okay, for the sake of your viewing experience, let me roll it
all the way back. Start it up from the beginning. We'll take
a look. Okay. >> Of all of America's much more
violence.
Okay. It's the same reason as to why America Ka, please just
[__] go. Just stop. Jesus Christ. What are you doing?
You're being such a baby. It's just you're making her stressed.
I I I She just literally is is so incredibly spoiled from my
mom.
Dude, so I saw a couple comments. They're like, "Oh, yeah. She's
spoiled in that the mom lets her stand up." I'm just like, "Okay,
I I don't know, man." >> No, she doesn't want to come over
here to see what's up. She just wants to roam the house because
she got to roam the house when I was gone. >> And she >> This
is This is the thing is I think Hassan is trying to do something
akin to kennel training with the dog. I think >> needs
to literally have the same structured regimented
I think this clip went to Trump's big baby desk immediately.
I just I hate everything. I just Uh, it's not a good looking
clip. I can say that. Although, if he just doesn't have a shot
collar, right? Or if he doesn't have something. No, no, no, no,
no. You, Lots of people don't let their dogs roam around.
And there's no reason to think that that dog needs all of the
time in the day to roam around because I believe Hassan takes
it out. I believe that dog goes like basically the rest of the
day is a lot of activity. I think that dog gets a lot of activity.
So, here's the thing. Psychologically, what are you doing to
the dog
if you are trying to create like an invisible kennel for it?
That's what I think this comes down to like with a shot collar
or with some kind of like
I don't know. Typing Kaya now in Hassan's chat is risking a permanent
ban. There's no way. Really? Really? It seems to me like it would
be really bad to have the threat of like harm from an invisible
thing for like leaving that pad during his stream. That seems
like I don't know how you recover from those optics if if it
comes out that that's what's going on here 100%. Right. Um I
the dog could maybe figure it out, but it's like I don't know.
You're doing it for a stream. That's that's dicey, man. If that's
what's actually happening, like I don't know if it's more cruel
than what people already do with their dogs necessarily. I don't
know if it's even necessarily more cruel, but if you're like
trying to keep the dog in frame for your stream all the time
and you're doing like this kind of Oh boy, that would be rough.
That would be rough. I He is streaming. I'm guessing he will
address it at some point, but also I don't know.
This is one of those moments where he had something happen here
that needs to be addressed. Okay, it's a pretty big deal. It's
pretty massive. It needs to be addressed, but I don't know if
he can like pause and review the clip and like talk his way out
of it either. Like he might need time to come up with a statement.
You know what I'm saying? He might be scared to stop. You're
saying it's just an optics dog? No, I think he loves his dog.
I think he loves his dog and takes care of his dog, but I think
it's also an optics dog, possibly. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. I I get
what you're saying, Happy Clams. So then I'm leaning towards
that wouldn't be something equivalent to training like to kennel
training a dog. People, a lot of people are like, "Oh, you can't
just expect a dog to like lay there all day." And I'm like, "Well,
no, for like several hours, for like 6 7 8 hours. You could expect
a dog to lay there. Lots of lots of people do that, but to train
them to lay there, I don't know what's going on. Isn't it just
that the dog is making noise?" Well, yeah, kind of. >> Of
all of America's much more
>> I tried watching to see if Ka is like trying to
>> get up and like trip or if she could have pain in her
joints here. I don't see it. same reason as to why America ka
please just go just stop
>> like it maybe maybe there's some way she pinched her
like toe I don't know if this is springs here if it's like a
trampoline or something I don't see it giving so
Jesus Christ what are you doing you're being such a baby how
old is the dog the dog's not old but it's like it's like a breed
that is
I don't know different kind of breed here let me go see if I
can find a clip on his channel and get a time stamp. Let's Let's
try to find the time stamp so we have higher We need higher definition.
Okay, we need the the full VOD here. Higher definition.
Let's check it out. What do we got
on and Kaya?
Oh, it would be very early. It would be around right here. Hold
on. Let's go see if we can see when he's
>> he gets back to it around 8 8:24 8:06 something like
that on the video. There's no way he finished the video. So Oh,
okay. No, maybe he did. I guess we could wait for Kai to move.
There is Ka moving somewhere around here. >> Conduct the
current.
>> Yeah, this is Jonathan Greenblat's favorite audience
>> moves back. Well, I'm just I'm just scanning for a time
stamp here, guys. >> Boris is because of using
>> she's sitting like that
>> specifically go to a pro Palestine rally an anti.
>> Anyway, as I was saying, >> I will just be your
pain. >> It's got to be right here. Yeah, it's right here.
Yeah, there it is. Economy.
>> There we are. Thank you for the donation, Reuben. Reuben.
No, I got I got it. This is where Silicon Valley is. This is
where all the Latest advancements in tech high def. Okay.
Got it in high def.
>> I'll turn it up.
>> You can be
Please just America's much more
violence.
Okay. It's the same reason as to why America Ka, please just
go. Just stop. Jesus. Reason as to why America
>> I can't tell. I'm like looking at the dog to see if
uh if there's anything in
>> Ka please just
>> the thing that gets me
>> is the is like there's a clear yelp and like a shock
there's like a clear shock surprise that happens here right >> Jesus
Christ what are you doing
such a baby well people are saying it's a shock caller but I
don't know here let's check out some of the LSF comments here
these are going to be interesting Okay. Do you see what's going
on in these comments?
What the
Just a colossal piece of poor dog is traumatized with how carefully
he tries it to it tries to leave. Uh if he's doing that on camera,
I hate to think what he does offline.
Yikes. The way he flounders after she yelps because it's so obvious
what he just did. Piece of wof.
I do think Okay. I do think that it seems Oh, man. It's hard
to argue that it's not something happening explicitly from him.
GG is in heaven. Probably. >> Jesus Christ. What are you
doing? You're being such a baby. >> Let's see what the
chat has to say. What the did you do to her? You monster. >> It's
just You're making her stressed. I I She just literally is is
so incredibly spoiled from my mom.
>> I'm not saying this. I'm reading everybody else's stuff.
People don't
people evaluate all kinds of relationships, even human animal
relationships, by like what the ideal should be at all times
because they're on camera, right? And it's like, no, probably
most people will get into like arguments or they'll be like annoyed.
They won't be like perfectly loving all the time. There can be
moments where people are like at at like kind of mad at each
other or not acting their best.
But this one
ultimately if it comes out that he's like using a shock collar
to keep Kaia on screen
that's hard to defend. Okay, that part right there if if
Matt cuz I you know what's happening now, right? Everybody's
going to go evaluate like every time Kaio was on stream to see
how she was being controlled to stay on that like pad. Right.
Right.
I feel like that's going to happen a lot. Now I grabbed one clip
here. Let's see if this is something tangible cuz I don't know.
Tan >> situation without a shot. >> I think this
is possibly before he got Ka. So
I don't know >> what the are you talking about. This is
why shot collars think she's too far away to correct her behavior
manually. She's not doing anything that bad. She's just jumping
because she's excited to see my mom.
And uh Oh, talking about a Oh boy.
Talking about a shot caller. Uhoh.
Hold on. Let's Let's get back to where he starts talking about
this. Okay.
Oh, it is totally Ka jumping up on his mom. >> Damn, bro.
Your dog sucks. Uh, take a week off for that. 27 month subscriber.
Suck my dick. My dog is incredible. This is why shock callers
are >> Bro, how people found this? I went and found it
right now. >> I think she's too far away to correct her
behavior manually. She's not doing anything that bad. She's just
jumping because she's excited to see my mom and uh that's it.
That doesn't mean that you can't remedy that situation. Uh, and
you can certainly remedy that situation without a shot collar.
What the are you talking
>> Okay, that is
has
has there ever been a time where Hassan's changed his opinion
on this? Sounds like he doesn't want a shot caller right here.
>> So, like, >> let me see here.
>> She's a five-month old dog. I'm just look going >> I'm
going to I'm sitting here. I'm wondering if he if he's just going
to ignore it because it's kind of crazy if he just ignores it,
dude.
I feel like you I feel like you kind of gota go and talk about
it when it's this big on LSF right now. But Hassan Hassan's pretty
good at also taking those situations and then not doing what
he should be doing, right? >> He's right. Your dog's broke
and get a new one. Okay, shut the [__] up.
Bunch of freaks in here, dude. >> Uh Top Bronson, yes,
that is my analysis. That's what I think as well. Tourism and
tourists are clogging up servers in West Mau, which is uh only
has one paved road. >> Okay. Well, somebody suggested a
a shot caller apparently for how Kai jumped up on his mom. So,
there's there is Ka. Full full on Kai Cam here.
>> Full on Kai Cam. >> Okay. Okay. Hey, hey, hey,
chill out.
Dr. An is here. Yeah. Okay. Let's get back to now that we had
a quick little cute break. A cutie pie break. Time to get back
to some serious news.
>> and I'm guessing at some point he gets called away after
this. Okay.
It's called away at some point. And Okay. Got it. Got it. I just
don't see the come over here to see what's up. She just [__]
go. Just stop. >> He looks He clear. Okay. I listen.
>> Okay. Moving around. It's the same reason as to why
America Ka please just
>> Why won't this pause? Hello.
>> Hold on. I need to slow down here. >> It's the
same reason as to why America
>> He rolls his eyes. Ka please. He looks down at something.
His first reaction when Ka's misbehaving is to look down and
to his left. >> He looks down to his left. >> [__]
it. >> He reaches out. He grabs something,
>> right? He reaches out, grabs something.
>> Yelp.
Just stop. >> Jesus Christ. What are >> And then
you hear the click of him putting something down with that hand
as >> America. Ka, please just go. Just stop. >> Watch.
Looks back. Listen to when this left hand drops. You hear him
put something back down.
>> I I don't know, man. Phone. Obvious. Could be a phone.
Could be a phone. Could be a phone. It's possible. >> Christ.
What are you doing? you're being such a baby. It's just now it's
possible.
It's possible.
Not not necessarily for sure, but it is possible that something
in how he's saying like Ka stop
is going to make her yelp like pull back and yelp and or she
missteps and she yelps because she gets scared. Dogs will yelp
when they get scared. This is a thing. They don't have to be
in pain necessarily. They'll yelp if they're afraid. >> You're
making her. But I lean towards the initial interpretation when
I slow it down and I see him look to his left. He seems to pick
something up. Ka jumps. He puts something down. I lean towards
something being there. Okay. Possibly sweatpants freedom. You'd
have to have a very good like I just don't think that that would
be true. But the dog would also just be totally chill staying
here. And then I feel like there'd be a lot of other signs of
stress on the dog that you don't really see.
But I don't know. Hey, I'm giving you both sides of what this
is, AC reel. Just just so you know, I'm giving you both sides
of what this could be to me. I tend to lean towards the dog shocking.
All right, that's where I lean.
That's where I lean. Now,
let's see. I believe Ethan Klein's already jumped on this. I
think I saw an Ethan Klein Instagram post. Ethan Klein calls
out Hassan for the Kaya clip. Horrifying animal cruelty caught
on camera by Hassan as he activates her shock collar for one
tiny step off of her bed. She cries in pain. Poor baby. I always
thought it was extremely bizarre that this his young, energetic
puppy never took a step off her bed. That has to be the result
of some brutally strict training. Jeez. Okay.
I think you could train a dog to do this. I think
ah
man this there's a couple different things going on here. Okay.
I think you could train a dog to do this. I think that reaction
doesn't lead me to believe that the dog's been trained to do
this in like a super nice way, super kind
Oh, right. You guys want me to do the Ethan counter propaganda?
Okay, hold on just a second. Just a sec. You want me to do the
the pronged collar? What is uh
why the prong collar on one of his dogs? Prong collar is completely
humane and has universal approval in the training world for big
dogs. Chief weighs over 80 lbs. if he doesn't learn to not pull,
he can seriously hurt someone. The someone the reason we got
it is because our trainer told us to. I mean, that might be true.
See, I'm I'm going to lean in this direction that like I want
to talk I would want to talk to somebody who trains dogs and
is very familiar because I do think there are a lot of things
that are just part of the course for training uh dogs, okay,
that you actually that people will just say are like horrifying
animal cruelty like this person like that will totally soy about
it. Jeez. Uh, Hassan used the shot color and probably has it
at a low setting and that's why she's being a baby. Is it a move
or lazy training? Yes. Is it abuse? Nah, miss me with that. Um,
oh man, it depends. I think for the purpose of sitting in frame
on your on your stream, that's that's a little much. And I don't
know how you get away from that, you know. Okay, hold on. People
are people are looking at evidence here.
We need to get YMS's YMS's opinion on this. Very possibly. Very
very possibly. So, the the only person who can tell us whether
or not this is okay. Adam, is this worse? IS THIS BETTER OR worse
then the dog? Adam, tell me now. I don't know.
Okay. Uh, okay. I had another post here with the guy. Oh, yes.
Accelerate. This spot right here has a frame that has a bulky
thing with a white or gray patch in the middle. There are quite
a few shot colors that look similar, like the Pat P301.
The heck? What the? Let me pull up the image here. uh that you're
saying this looks like a possible possibly a shock color. I'm
going to say it's almost certainly impossible to decide because
of how
fuzzy this dog is. I I don't know how if it's possible to determine
the shock color like >> his fear pay. >> Oh, hold
on. Three bucks. >> Rean Ruben donated $3. Would you suggest
the same shock collar that you used to keep Cherry on stream?
Smile. >> Very weird comment, Reuben, but won't ban you
for it. Very weird comment though. Okay. Has Vosch spoken about
this? No, I don't think I don't think anyone's spoken about it.
I'm waiting for Hassan to comment. Hassan's not commenting. How
does Hassan continue to not comment? Oh, hold on. He got stuck.
He got stuck somewhere. >> I mean, this is this is the
meta. What is this?
Taylor Swift attempts to silence critic. ACLU fights back. Wait,
what the >> Oh, he's he's on the Swifty stuff. I
bro. We don't we don't have any comment from him. He knows that
this is blowing up, dude. I guarantee you if you were to do like
analysis on his stream right now, he is going to be like third
monitor. Okay. Checking LSF constantly to see what's happening,
what's going on with this stuff. Okay. Have we gotten Have we
gotten any other clips
just to add to the Hassan situation? This one was the what? The
two tight collar one. >> My old roommate wanted to use
a shot collar or um fish and his dogs.
um for fish and his dogs barking.
I couldn't do it. I have it still. I bought it. >> Yeah.
So, I've seen a couple clips where Hassan basically says like
a shot color. That's unacceptable. I don't want a shot color
my dog. So, very, very interesting if he's been changed on that
over time for fish. No, no, no, no, no, no, no. Fish was the
name of his old dog. How do you guys not know that fish was the
name of his old dog?
regarding the Hassan situation. Oh god, is this going to be some
zoomed in slowed down? >> Okay, it's the same reason as
to why >> Oh, I did not see any of her paws or nails stuck
anywhere.
>> Just [__] go. Just stop.
>> I I don't know. It's >> Oh, go. >> What's
up? Well, I just so you know, they can't hear you at all. >> Okay.
Oh, I see. Like, kaite. Yeah, sure. Sure. So Cherry is just saying
that like it's possible she's been trained to stay on there in
some way and that Hassan like reaches for something and he's
not shocking her or whatever, but she's like recoiling. Yeah,
this is what I just noticed as well. Canadian
>> was
when the thing happens, right? You see you see her recoil her
paw up off the ground like I'm on the bed. I'm on the bed. I'm
on the bed.
>> She She does pull her paw up like Hold >> That's
like It's directly up. >> [__] go. Just stop.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yep.
Yeah. I think um Hassan likes basically what he tells Hassan
wants it so that when he tells Ka to lay down and stay, she does
that, right? And
Hassan's mom doesn't keep any of that same discipline going.
She reefs it up like she stepped on something. Well,
>> yes. to >> I think it's >> Please just [__]
>> I think she knows she's not supposed to be off the back.
>> I to me it's the other paw that looked like it got stuck
though.
>> It would be to me it looked like this paw that like
something might have been up with like this. It's not the other
paw. It's like this paw that like
But I don't know. I don't know. I'm I'm just trying to see. Did
we get anything else from LSF? Is there any new stuff here?
Son's guess is his dog's collar is too tight. We watch that one.
It's on reaching for something. Yeah,
dude. How is this like this is four of the top four of the top
five postatic
of all of America's much more consequential
>> Let's see.
Mom spoils her. She a lot of people pointing out the the idea
that Kai is a prop, which again I I don't know how you get away
from that. Okay. A lot of kids watch Dumbo. A lot of kids didn't
like Dumbo. A lot of kids are traumatized by Dumbo. All right.
If he's using Kai as like a prop and and he's basically trained
her to stay still on stream for precisely just that reason as
I don't know how I don't know how you make that better, man.
That's rough, dude. Well, hold on. There's a difference between
Ka being just a total prop and
just having Kaia's bed there and letting her come and lay down
and be a part of the stream, right?
Like there are animals that will want to come lay down by like
by their owner. In my head, oh, how do I explain it? In my head,
it was like, okay, if Kai wants to be in this room, she's she
has to lay on her bed while I'm while I'm at work. And I would
like want to train the dog to be able to do that or they could
be outside. Either one. Either one. Let's see here. I People
are
I don't know. There's uh
there is a way that you could like know the answer to this and
it would involve going through like since Hassan had this configuration
going through and seeing like how Ka
how Ka deals with it. Oh, Hassan says Ka clipped herself on something.
Uhoh.
Oh boy.
He's denying He's denying that there is anything to this. Okay,
let me see here. Go to new. We go to new. We check it out. Hassan
regarding shot callers. Son claims Ka clipped herself on something
while getting off. Kai was nowhere near something.
>> Is there like a [__] LSF video or something?
Is that why there's like hella people coming in here and and
>> Ah, yeah. That's why. >> Is that what's going
on?
just cuz I'm like a streamer now. I know how like manufactured
this kind of reaction is, right? Like you know that you'd have
some way of getting messages from people on stream. You know
that you'd be getting DM'd by people like while this is happening.
You know that like you know all of these things, right? You know
all of it. So
she did seem to raise her right paw when she whed higher than
the other. Yes. Yeah. She pulled that paw up off the >> For
sure.
>> He's getting messages from people. They're telling them
what's going on. >> Is a classic pipeline. I'm going to
die,
>> It did go like that. It literally took It literally
took the exact path. I I don't know if you guys saw I'll show
you the first tweet I saw it on. Okay. The first Twitter account.
It actually was Asmin Gold though. I think it might have been
Asmin Gold.
It was the Asmin Gold people. This is This is the one.
Be a dog. Stand up. Hassan Michael Vic Per for some reason. I
am Adolf H. Dan's not got a lot of subtlety to him, does he?
Not a whole lot of subtlety to Dan. So, this was like the original
one I saw at
I doubt somebody posting in the Asmin
I don't know if this would be a Oh, wait. Hold on.
Yeah. No, this isn't uh this is not like a like a DGR or something.
Yeah, I I would I don't think it' be uh
the Daliban. Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
I wonder how somebody does that. I feel like that might be the
biggest disconnect between like large scale large influencers
I've ever seen,
right? Like if you were to be like a fan of Destiny and Asmin
Gold at the same time. How in the world
How in the world could you manage that? You'd have to be so brain
damaged to manage that in any sensible way. I don't know. Crazy.
All right. Asold said he was withholding judgment for a day.
H
very interesting.
I I think it looks
kind of like he got shocked.
I think Hassan if what's the other thing? If Hassan was actually
innocent here, I do think
he could easily just go pull Ka over, pull a camera over to Kaa
and show the collar and show it's not a shock collar and everything
would be fine. Right.
That's That's like the obvious answer. He could He could pull
Kyle over to the camera, go, "She doesn't even wear a shot collar.
Look, take the collar off and show." It's not even a shot collar,
man. That's not even a shock. Couldn't possibly be, right? So,
it's it's easily
I don't know if he would do that anyway. He'd just go, "Oh, it's
unhealthy. It's It's like unhealthy for me to to lean into this."
XQC said 98.5% proven. Ah,
I don't know about that one. Really?
Hold on. I'm gonna have to I'm gonna have to examine the XQC
coverage. Okay. Excuse XQC is not the most reliable guy sometimes.
Okay.
>> Not the most reliable guy. >> I'm I'm hearing
that he may have examined. Okay. >> Did he examine it?
>> Is he going to examine? Oh, here we go. >> We're
looking at our our Kai examination. Okay. What is the juicer
>> Jesus Christ. What are you doing? >> I don't see
it. >> Of all of America's much more >> Is it under
its fur? >> Violence.
Okay. It's the same reason as to why America Ka, please just
go just >> Chad, did he did he debunk it? Chad, did he
debunk it? >> Did he debunk it?
>> Guys, Chad, guys, you guys might not like this [__]
guys. I'm going to do a debunker segment, guys. I know some of
you guys don't like it. >> Okay, hold on. I just realized
I need to I need to actually finish this
>> H3 then LS7 is a classic pipeline. >> I need I
need to get Hassan's statement here. I forgot we went and looked
at where the clip came from. We need Hassan's actual statement.
We need his updated statement >> before we go to Felix.
>> I'm going to die, dude. Yes, I am uh incredibly abusive
to the not only best trained
but also
the
best behaving and most spoiled dog on the planet is from when
Ka yelped. Yeah, she yelled because she clipped herself on something
when she was getting off the bed. So, pull up the clip. Pull
up the clip. Let's see the clip, man.
Oh, he's not going to analyze the clip on the stream. That's
a tough one. That's a tough one for me. Okay. I feel like Hassan,
you got to look at the clip, man.
>> I had to do >> Seriously, those beds are bad.
>> Oh, can we figure out the the model of the bed? Can
we figure out the model of that dog bed? Cuz I do think her left
paw goes on there. And it looks like she might have like caught
it somehow and brought her right paw up to try to get her balance
or something. Possibly. >> I will debunk it
or undebunk it. Oh,
>> I think her collar is too tight. >> Well, it's
uh Are we
>> It's You have to You have to be able to get two fingers
and I couldn't even get one. I think >> this is like >> This
is poisoning the Well,
>> You shouldn't watch this clip. >> Neck meat. >> You
have to You have to be able to >> Oh, sorry. Uh Pixel Relapse.
I I understand that for people who are like at your IQ level,
I should probably say that like still 90% on the shot color.
That's probably not obvious to you. I'm just saying there are
other things that could possibly be happening here that I'm giving
like a low probability to. But I I see that you're struggling
with, you know, normal human conversation. Not shocking. Not
shocking, but I'll I'll try to make it more clear for you >> to
get two fingers and I couldn't even get one. I think you're choking
her. >> She's like >> her collar is too tight. >> Well,
it's uh Are we?
>> Um, chat, show me the VA. Show me the VA. Chat, >> I'm
saying the most likely thing that that I see out of this fra
is a shock color. That's the thing that I see as most likely
right now. >> Have the vaude. >> He's going to pull
out. >> Why America ka please just [__] go.
>> stop. I can see his motion. We chat. We must go deeper.
You do need the full vod soy boy.
>> Our movement now a little bit more. >> So FCC
had the exact same content thought as me. I feel like that's
that's both haunting and awesome. Okay, >> you slow down
a little bit more.
>> A little bit more.
>> Now it's it stops now.
>> Oh, his timing is
Huge news for the unemployed.
Just
>> it is huge news for the unemployed. >> I will
take it off because what are >> they would be weird to
accuse him like that. I'm just going with the people saying people
saying his dog is a shot
>> Massive news for the unemployed. Obviously it is. >> I
was I was more say no way he has that cuz he's muji sensible
guy.
um it looks pretty like the gem thing and then 90%. >> Oh
man. I don't know. I don't know if I could do 99% on this.
I think we got to find the model of the bed. The model whatever
model of dog bed this is. We got to find it. Can we find other
examples? What would be the quickest way to find other examples
of Kaia getting off the bed?
Cuz I I would love to see if there's any There's got to be other
clips, right? Ka is on that bed often enough
that there's got to be like a >> legends who were there
years ago when Taylor Swift was >> essentially making her
>> classic Hassan stream. Classic. Absolutely classic.
Yesterday's VOD 10559.
Hold on cuz what we need is we have to see when Ka's getting
off the bed when she's looking like she's going to get
What will Hassan do? What does he do?
What was it? 10559.
Okay. 1 hour 5
>> right here. >> You're new kind of getting down.
>> Trump's talking big.
So he mutes and he just gives Kaia a command to go lay back down,
right? There's nothing there. Now what we'd be looking for here
is a look off to his left. Okay. Does he look over to his left
before he gives the command or before when he notices her getting
up off the bed? >> Edit uh acting as though they're besties.
But >> we see him look off to his left.
Uh your Newsome is saying like uh Caesar up >> like Trump
is talking Trump is talking
>> I don't see him look over for like a a thing so I actually
don't know right he he just pauses he gives her like a command
says Kai get back on the bed and then she does
>> not tapped D's car exactly where to go this hilarious
yes >> troops when asked about his plan >> where
does Kai go here >> think in retros
laying down >> on the test we don't have lower >> what
what happened here >> it is what it is anyway
while I'm waiting for Oh god I'm gonna actually let Kai out because
I can't stand her uh being in the background and like and wanting
attention as well. Okay. Okay. Up. Get out of here. Go.
Go. Go. Go. Go. Go. >> Okay. This is a thing. This is a
thing that I think could easily be the case. Okay. Hypothetically,
Ka, if she's going to be in the office, Ka has to be laying down,
right? I think that's got to be like the thing. And then she
gets like antsy and he's like, "Well, either you're in or you're
out,
But I don't think he necessarily like just don't have the dog
in the room. Hold on. You understand? Has anybody ever owned
a dog? You understand the dog will want to be with you. Have
you owned a cat? People know this with cats that a cat will be
upset with you. They'll want in the room and then you'll let
them in the room and then they'll be like, "No, you I don't want
to be in this room." Why does What? How does nobody How do you
forget that this this is a thing? His stream deck is on the left.
Oh well,
bro. Where did he get the API integration from the Steam Deck
to his shot caller? That's crazy. See, left side. That's his
stream decks there. And then he could have whatever else over
here. Okay. All right. Then don't have the dog in the room. Don't
lock dogs in a room for eight plus hours a day. Does he do that
though? Can we find a a video where Kai is just laying there
the entire day? Cuz I don't I don't think that would be reasonable,
but I don't think that's happening. >> Two really cute
lines as well. 7 hours and 41 minutes. And let's see how often
time is
>> and then talking about the event.
>> Oh, this is some other thing. Hold on. I didn't even
see this. A different >> potential shelf life as a public
figure. >> 7-hour VOD right here. 7-hour VOD. Let's take
a look. He's telling this one. God damn it.
Why? It's not obvious to me that he >> soft pop rock instrumental
pallets that you might catch on a Fleetwood Mac classic, but
then it bursts. >> 4 hours. 4 hour VOD. out more. >> It's
for the subscriptions and
>> Do I want to talk?
>> Getting kind of antsy >> or division.
>> Rean Rubin donated $3. Remember when Hassan called someone
a bloodthirsty pig dog? Funny how his dog looked like a >> Okay.
and liquor test.
>> Then your son enter some of the
>> see
to try and
>> live at Seattle city hall with more on the state's message
to the white house. Sean, good morning. >> Phil, good morning.
and both the mayor of Seattle as well as Washington's attorney
general making those comments together before what we just heard
from the president and any clear sign that troops are actually
coming to Seattle. But even with those recent comments the president
made both of these leaders saying that they want to be prepared
and sharing what they might be able to do to try and
>> stop troops from arriving here or at least fight that
decision to Seattle Mayor Bruce Herrell explaining that he plans
to release an executive order.
>> Dude, did she just did she just get away with that whole
thing? >> With actions the city can take if the Washington
National Guard is mobilized. Attorney General Nick Brown says
the state is ready to challenge the Trump administration in court,
but couldn't say for sure who would have the final. >> Then
she just comes and lays back down. Okay. All right.
I Man,
I'm leaning towards this being shown to be nothing a little bit
more. Like I'm starting to get back to like 20 30% this is nothing.
I think I think I think like I'm back to like 20 30% this is
just nothing. Let me go look at anything new. Anything new? I
don't want to post. I I don't plan on posting on this sub again,
but I want to put this debate to rest. Ka was not electrocuted
by a shock collar. Her due claw got caught in between part of
the elevated bed. You can feel free to say his reaction was still
unwarranted, but he did not shock >> Violence.
Okay, it's the same reason as to why America ka please. >> Oh,
hold on. See, that's what I said. This that was one of the things
I listed. Left paw goes down.
Left paw goes down. Dog immediately recoils the other paw back
up.
Now, I don't know. I don't know how that helps. It looks a little
weird. This looks different than the original. Does it though?
But does it Does it truly look different than the
Where we at here? We go to today. Let me go back to today's VOD.
Let me go back.
How did these feelings or observations? >> How much insane
hyper analysis can we do on this? We're going to test the limits.
Okay, about 3 minutes in for the KA moment here. >> Such
a first world problem.
This uh states on please just go just
>> I don't know man.
violence.
Okay. It's the same reason as to why America ka please just go
>> down. It immediately jumps back up.
I'm telling you that left paw.
She puts weight on that left paw and immediately immediately
yelps.
Wait, why are people saying 100% doesn't have anything to do
with the paw? Okay. It's the same
reason as to why America ka please just
I don't know. I don't know. What am I putting it on? I think
I'm like 7030 right now. Sofa King. Like 7030. He shocked a dog.
7030. He shocked a dog. 7030. He should just He should just show
the Yes, he should just show the collar. Okay, hold >> Jesus
Christ. What are you doing?
You're being such a baby. It's just You're making her stressed.
I
>> does the color look any different? I mean, I don't know
how we do that analysis. Okay, that's like a difficult analysis
to pull off. No, no, no, no, no. I don't think people will say
that now, Top Bronson. But if he ends and then he shows later,
that that that's not going to matter to anyone. It's why we'd
have to show now.
Why doesn't he check on her after yelping though? Because she's
showing no visible signs of distress after that. He's literally
She's showing no like visible signs of distress.
I'm sorry. I Anybody who's like, "Oh, the dog yelled. Why aren't
you going to check on it immediately?" I It's just like I don't
know. I feel like you guys
a man. It is what it is.
The posts are getting deleted now. LSF mods have woken up. What?
Oh, Hassan is bad. Hassan is bad. Han is bad. Okay, a couple
of these got taken out.
Now, did the most recent one get taken out? It did. It did get
taken out. Do we have any other?
Do we have any other commentary? Not yet. Okay. No commentary
on LSF. Let's check Let's check O. We got any O commentary on
this? Cuz otherwise, it's seeming like maybe maybe we'll have
to move on to actual content for the day. Maybe I can't milk
anything else out of the Hassan Collar segment. Okay,
we had the XQC stuff. We watched we watched XGC 98%. Let's see
here. Oh, Ana. Ana came in apparently and tweeted about Hassan.
Okay, so Ana says, "I'm a big dog advocate. Love training dogs
with positive reinforcement as you can tell with Merlin and Fiona
on Ian streams. I met Ka. I saw Ka while Hassan was streaming.
She never had a shock collar on. She was good at her place command,
but that's very easily accomplished with positive reinforcement.
I would be very very surprised if this was actually Ka reacting
to a shot collar. Just because Ethan's a horrible dog owner and
can't train his dogs worth [__] doesn't mean other
people are using shock collars.
I mean, she has been at his house. We watch it sped up now. Okay.
You know what? That's a good point.
That's a good point.
Some people might not know what we're talking about. If you're
just getting here, if you're just trickling in late, guys,
there's a massive controversy going on right now where people
believe there's evidence that Hassan shocks his dog Ka to keep
her on stream like she's basically Dumbo. Okay, he abuses this
animal. That is the accusation that he abuses this animal to
keep it on stream and keep it entertaining his audience. of all
of America's much more
violence.
Okay. It's the same reason as to why America Ka, please just
go. Just stop. Jesus Christ. What are you doing? You're being
such a baby. It's just you're making her stressed. I I She just
literally is is >> There it is. >> So incredibly
spoiled from my mom. No, she doesn't want to come over here to
see what's up. She just wants to roam the house because she got
to roam the house when I was gone >> and she needs to literally
have the same structure
regimented. >> Hold on. That's like not the gift that I
>> I think this clip went to Trump's big baby desk immediately.
I just I hate everything. I just I hate everything.
>> Is this a really long gift? Oh, there we go. Yeah. What
the heck? I saw that frame of the GIF really. Okay, there we
go. Is that the reaction of someone who just sabed his dog? Let's
see. Ka, please just go back. Just stop. >> It does seem
like he looks over like he is like he might be concerned, right?
>> [__] go. Just stop.
>> Jesus Christ. What are you doing? You're being such
a B. If the paw hurt, the dog would lick it. Um, no. I don't
I don't I think if dogs do that when it still hurts. If they
get spooked by something, they don't necessarily do that. Maybe.
>> Okay, let me go back to
>> I She just literally
a a moment of anger. This is a moment of anger for like something
that is just so routine. Just talking about Palestine. Okay,
I'm just I'm spinning around looking for more um more stuff on
this cuz I think we've we've analyzed we've got our predictions
in. Okay,
I'm I'm just expecting that this is blowing up so much that Hassan
has no choice but to actually analyze it and respond directly
himself. This looks like the dog bed. Okay, hold on. Give me
a second. Let's open it up. This is going to be a meme that I
shouldn't be clicking on. Hold on. What a top Bronson link me.
Top Bronson, link it in DMs. Link it in DMs right now. Oh, some
people are linking it to me. Take a look here. Okay. Elevated
bed. Something like this. Something like this. Watching you back.
Oh, it was watching you back who linked it. Anyway,
what is this one? FXW. Okay, this is our dog bed we're working
with here. Now, I do wonder if you would see it like
it's nail catching or anything here. What are our one-star reviews?
Okay, I can't see the reviews. That's fine. I would just wonder
if you could get
>> nails getting caught in this bag. >> Ruben donated
something they'd know about it.
>> Thank you, Reuben Rubin, for the three. Appreciate it,
buddy. Pixel Relapse, you're welcome to your opinion. I I don't
know why me like exploring other options instead of just like
screaming about Hassan is triggering you so much. I have suspicions,
but
let's see here. I I just need Hassan to make a statement. Oh,
right. We're reading the Anaisa statement. So, she says they
don't use shock collars. Ethan responds, "What a pathetic stain
of a human being to immediately handwave any animal abuse and
instead try to turn it into on my four loved dogs. Anisa will
erase this tweet after more evidence of Hassan's animal abuse
comes to light.
I man, do we think that that's possible? That would be really
crazy, wouldn't it? If Hassan's been like abusing this dog, I
feel like I feel like Hassan's audience. That's like one thing
they wouldn't let him get away with. CPS visiting my family and
he's sleeps. Hassan caught abusing his dog on camera. I must
defend my friend.
He's seething. He's seething. Another angle of the dog bed. Okay,
hold on. They're all bagging.
I do just feel like like personally
okay. Yeah, that looks like that looks like the dog bed. I do
feel like just
he can't have like some long track record of abusing this animal
>> yard. Just don't show the the streets or >> Okay.
Well, it was just a different angle in the bed. Okay. >> I
will just be your pay.
>> Rean Rubin donated $3. Hassan is nose for hitting the
pause when watching videos. Such foreshadowing.
hitting the pause. Eh, and you spelled it like the like h
you missed out on a pun there. That's very uncharacteristic.
Reuben Ruben, I hope everything's okay. Hope you're all good,
buddy.
You You missed a pun. I I'm very worried for you. Thinks he's
doing what's best for Kaia. Well, I think he he might have trained
Ka to stay on the bed. I just
I wonder if Ana knows how Kaio was trained cuz here's the thing.
What I will say about this is it doesn't look like to me this
doesn't look like a response that is from
>> this isn't a response. If she is just concerned about
Hassan let's say she doesn't catch her tail her her nail or something.
Even if this weren't a shock this response it's like to me it's
like oh that's a clear sign of like negative reinforcement for
bad behavior not positive reinforcement for good behavior. reason
as to why America ka please just go just stop. Jesus Christ,
what are you doing?
Oh, Princess Psycha, I don't think that any shot color, any possible
shot color would truly be hurting this dog. This is a big ass
dog. Okay, this is a big ass dog. It's like super thick skin,
super thick coat, right? You're going to have an actual hard
time making a shot color do anything harmful to this dog. Like
this dog is just going to get scared by a shot collar. It's not
going to be like it's not going to be anywhere near that bad
for any like commercial grade shot collar. Whole bunch of people
spamming question marks because they've never bought a shot collar
for their dogs or they're I'm not sure which. Unless am I mistaken?
I thought this was like a I thought this was some kind of like
Tibetan
Alaskan
hunting dog. What kind of dog is this?
Can someone tell me what kind of dog this is? Fluffy.
I'm just saying that they'll have like a coat that's um really
really thick because it's a chow. So it is some kind of like
It's not a chow, bro. It's not a chow.
It's a Tibet ma. Yeah, it's a Tibetan mastiff.
Tibet mastiff Burmese mountain dog. It's a dog that's supposed
to be outside. It's supposed to be cold out. Okay, let's see
here.
Oh man, I think I think I've about farmed all I can from this.
Going to have to move on to anything else
at this point. Give me a quick sec. Let's check. Oh no. This
is just This is just not going to give this LSF clip. >> Is
there like a LSF video or something? Is that why there's like
hella people coming in here and and screeching? >> Oh,
hold on. I will say >> in the same positive association
with
>> That color looks like it could be something, right?
That looks like it could be a shock collar.
It does. Or I think there are also Hold on. Are there also like
uh what is it? Ultrasonic colors or whatever. This looks like
a shock collar to me. >> So all this does is breed resentment
against Israel. And also depending on >> Oh, hold on. Wait.
>> And the same positive association with >> Now,
can we figure out what kind of color this is? Let's I I want
to see what kind of color it is.
Is that why the color has to be tight? I've seen this said that
the color has to be tight because it's a shock color. Going with
GPS. Uh, is there any reason for it to be GPS? I thought they
basically inject that into the dog now. You can like chip your
dog, right? Well, this looks like Hold on. That looks like a
box like kind of popping off of it there. Chipping is an active
tracking.
maybe it could be something like GPS. >> So, all this does
is breed resentment.
>> Oh, wait. Hold on, hold on. We missed it. Look, >> this
does is breed resentment.
>> Look, look at the green. Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Did we Do we catch that? Did we catch that?
>> look at the green.
Oh boy. Is there going to be a lot of Is there going to be a
lot of these? Is Is that a GPS? I never seen a GPS collar like
that. I have seen I think some shot callers that do that. Okay.
I listen. That's working back in the shot color direction right
there.
>> Watch the green. Come on.
>> activate activate deactivate flash.
Okay, I think I think it's over and Kai's wearing a shot collar
100%.
And I think
given that we know wa that she's now wearing a shot collar, I
feel like you have to move back to the listen the 99%
scenario. Okay, this is such a roller coaster I want to believe.
Okay, we got to figure out what kind of collar could have this
thing on it. Okay, we've got the metal piece. We've got the the
battery pack thing here. Hold on a second.
What is this? What is this? We might need this. We need to see
what he's saying in this VOD so we could go look it up and find
the higher quality VOD here. Okay, in the same positive association
with Israel. So, all this does is breed resentment.
>> Same positive association with Israel. All this does
is breed resentment.
Um,
try to link me one. That's like a Garmin one. Let's check this
out real quick. There's this guy right here. Now, do we get any
other looks at this? But that's like about the size of the thing
that's
Kai's that's on Kai's thing. Oh, but also
it could be a barking collar, too,
right? Like it could actually not be a shot caller. Could be
a barking collar as well. Let's look at a couple of these other
ones
against Israel. And also depending on how >> Yeah, it looks
like there's that white oval piece. I think we could that could
be a buckle. Eh, I don't think so. I think there's like an actual
white circle there or like a a steel circle here. Now, hold on.
There's another one from Creger from Amazon. Let's check this
one out.
This one is a plate that could go on.
Oh, that's interesting.
Okay, so you get like a you get like a
You get a tag that air tags can go into. That looks like that's
what that could be for sure. That's possible. Um, there is unfortunately
another thing that's on there that looks like a shot collar.
This could be the circular metal piece. >> But there is
something else on there for >> Reuben donated $3. Do you
think that maybe she could have gotten shocked and also got her
poor cort? People looking for one or the other, but might be
botch things happened. >> Thank you for the three, Rubid.
Rubid, thank you.
Build trainer waterproof. Okay. What is this one? What is this
And that's Hold on. This um
No, I don't think that's it at all. I don't That doesn't look
like it at all to me. Um I will say knowing that this exists,
this like Air Tag thing, and that it might be something they've
heard of, that to me, oh man, that to me looks like that could
be what that is. And if that's what that is, then it's something
else going on with the uh with the green thing there. Okay, I
don't know if we can find anything on there.
Give me a second. I'm going to pull up Filmont.
I'm going to go caller.
Caller Kaya
within 15. Caller Ka within 15. We got We got VODs. Oh.
Oh, did I just did I just save
>> Did I just save Hassan Piker's career? >> I don't
know if you guys like real That's not true, brother. You have
issues, my man.
This is what I deal with every day. The moment that I This is
the worst part about it is that >> Hassan Hassan may be
cluing us in to what he actually did here. Okay. >> The
The worst part about it is that like chatters do take it seriously
and they lose their minds. Oh my god. I I'm going to take Ka
out to
get her a bark caller. She's being annoying. What are you insane?
I mean, Jesus Christ, dude. Yeah. >> Never mind. No, I
didn't say Fan's career. I thought he was going to say I thought
he was going to say, "Oh, I'm I'm thinking about getting her
a bark
But
he says, "No, that would be insane, dude. His comments about
shot collars and stuff. If he can't explain whatever the that
that thing is, these are going to be a a
>> 10 10 week old puppy. Let me get a bark collar for her."
>> Oh, okay. It's only that she's a 10. >> She's
a child. She'll learn. >> Yeah, that's reasonable. That's
>> Yeah, that's reasonable. Anyway,
>> bark colors are cool as they kind of are. Yeah. Uh,
can we just go collar?
Let me see if we can find anything from collar here.
This is going to get me a lot of stuff,
Um, oh, collar. Dog collar
15. Let's see. Let's see. We got anything else here? Diamond
encrusted dog collar. What is this? >> Dog wears a collar
with a chip in. >> Oh, that's from the game. A collar dog.
Not from the trainer. And it came from the dog. >> No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
Now, and his collar is still bust. Oh, this one. >> And
it came from the dog. Not from a trainer. Not from a leash. Not
from an e-collar. It is the most What is an e-collar? What is
an e-collar? Kaya.
I tried kaya earlier. There's going to be a lot of Kai Eclipse
here. Yeah, there's going to be a ton of Kai Eclipse. Unfortunately,
just too many Kai clips for us to sort through. Okay. What is
an e-collar? E-collar. A dog. E-collar. E-collar technologies.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. These these seem to just be
e-collars are the name for electric collars. So, nope. Not those.
Maybe he was buying. No, that was that was some other news thing
right there that we were looking at before.
Here, let's see. Sad new Asian sort of like a spike caller. Nope.
People. Okay. No. Uh, I don't think we've got anything here.
I don't think we got anything here. Checking in on LSF. Looking
for any updates. I've still not seen anything anything new since
we got from best friend in the same positive association with
Israel. So, all this does is >> GPS callers have a flashing
green light. Okay, let's try to find GPS collar. GPS
dog collar. What do we get popping up
GPS dog collars. I don't see that. Maybe
Delta SE dog training system.
That looks kind of like what it could be right there. That's
got a the green beep, but the green is on the front
camera collar. Okay, these are all shot collars. So, geez, give
me a second here. I'm going to >> Is it? >> We're
going to watch this on for 2 minutes while I use bathroom. Grab
some water. Oh, >> 100% about Blake Lively after the initial
tonedeaf comments and an article calling her canceled during
the movie press tour last summer before the Baldon stuff. She
wrote this album in the summer of 2024.
>> Oh, does it look like this? No. Here's the thing real
quick before we uh Oh, I forgot Taylor Swift was a part of the
Justin Beldon stuff. >> Okay, so someone was asking if
it's this caller right here. I don't think it could be this caller
right here.
>> I don't think so. But let's take a look real quick.
Do one more. Now >> the same positive association with
Israel. So all the >> See, it looks like this is more of
a box than it is like a a long rectangle,
I think. Okay, but I'm going to leave you with this on for a
I got to use the bathroom real quick. I'll be right back. >> That
is crazy. >> Ka's up. >> Ka's up. Ka's making another
RUN FOR IT. KA, RUN.
>> OKAY. What do you want? >> See, to me, >> what
do you want from >> that dog is clearly trained very well,
Like, as soon as he says, "Okay, up." She gets up. >> Those
of you who ask, why do you always do the place command? The reason
why I always do the place command is because she likes to lay
on the ground. Okay? She likes to be by my side, but she likes
to lay on the ground.
And the reason why
I don't like letting her lay on the ground as opposed to that
bed is because the bed is because
the bed is better for her joints.
Okay? Get her a better bed then. No, that bed is perfectly fine
for her because when she lays on the ground as a big girl, it
up her joints. Don't let him lie to you, Chad. It's because he's
a terrorist. Yeah. Why do you need to tell people this? Did something
happen? Yes. Uh it's going viral that they're uh claiming that
the most well-trained and the most spoiled,
best kept after dog
on the planet is actually being abused by me apparently because
I gave her the place command while she was getting off
and then um she yelped. Okay, >> these shadows don't know
she broke the other beds. Yeah,
>> she'd broken the previous bed, bro. That dog is being
abused every day on I can't imagine. Yeah, and I uh I I suspect
it's coming from,
you know, some crazy
>> They said you're shocked with a button.
in my evil villain lair. Good thing I didn't hit the trap door
button instead on accident. I So >> she reviewed the food
online. She yelled. No, she went when she was getting off the
bed. >> I
dude, come on. Just show Just show the caller. Show us funny
or clipped or show us the color, man.
>> show us the collar, dude. >> I don't know. >> Yeah,
it came from the H3 sub. They didn't even hide it. >> Man,
you guys are saying this. I feel like I can see a lot of
>> I've seen him interacting with his dog and I've never
seen his dog >> every time we get heated up. All the same
drama freaks activated. Yes.
>> Like I don't know. I think people just aren't used to
having to seeing like well-trained dogs. They don't like it.
Is it going to be in the next content?
Nuke, I'm confused. How did she get shocked or is that fake there?
I don't There is no way for her to be shocked. That is fake.
Oh, buddy.
Okay, so I need to know what kind of color that is then, right?
That's all. Listen, I I can sweep for this guy, but are saying
you don't take her out? Isn't she obly trained? And you literally
take her out every day. Yes. >> Whatever caller is
>> whatever caller that is. Okay. >> Across the threads
is like 10k replies in an hour. Bots and astroturf. So dumb.
It is what it is. What are you going to
>> It could just be a GPS caller. It could just be a GPS
caller. That's reasonable.
I still feel like
I still feel like I've moved past 50/50.
It might be worse than 50/50. We might be back. >> Seven
LSF threads about this. Either made like six Instagram posts
about it. There's no real drama here. It's 100% manufactured.
Shared on the sub. There's real drama. >> Went to KKK3
sub and then went to LSF. Probably did Diddy Dan Astroturfing
again. Yeah, bro. I never get threads notifications about this
one, but I got >> I'm just hoping he'll look at a chat
message that says, "Could you just show us the caller? Could
you just show us the caller? I just want to see the caller, man.
I want to I want to see the caller, and I don't want to hear
about >> Bobby is the CIA.
>> Plant is an activist now. >> Got a whole news
thread." It did. Oh, >> what's your verdict on Taylor Swift?
I think everyone is out of control. Israel calls prominent Democrat
mouthpiece for blistering October 7th post. Israel foreign minister
said
only when they are dead.
>> All right, let's get back to the Taylor tweet Taylor.
>> This point from the pop world of you know many a single
many a record that analyzes
do that. What is this? >> I'm I'm backing it up a little
bit. I want to see started talking about Ka here. is a boomer's
first interaction with uh
with uh
this whatever this is
>> mid to horny how she has fringe or tonedeaf vibe >> like
do we know is uh or not Patrick Mahomes Patrick Mahome's wife
is wife
>> okay she's going through this [__] >> it
feels like you're saying the opposite
>> are you a fan of the shorts and
abysmal fit.
Especially including the the the the shoes as well.
That is craziness.
That is crazy. >> Mods have been timing out. People asking
to see the color. Not good. Not good.
>> What are you doing?
>> Okay. What do you want? >> What do you want from
me? >> Okay. For those of you who ask why do you always
do the place command, the reason why I always do the place command
is because she likes to lay on the ground. Okay, she likes to
be by my side, but she likes to lay on the ground.
And the reason why
I don't like
>> You don't seriously believe this, right? >> letting
her lay. >> I want to see the collar for sure.
I think it looks very suspicious the timing of everything. But
I also feel like the dog is very well trained,
>> Problem. But oh, the joint thing could be true. Big
big dogs have really bad problems with their joints. Maybe this
is like the reason you want the bed off the ground. I don't know.
It is emblematic of all of America's much sequential
violence.
Okay. It's the same reason as to why America Ka, please just
go back. Just stop. Jesus Christ, what are you doing? You're
being such a Yeah. Here's the thing that I'm thinking now is
I think there's like a reason.
Personally, I think there's a reason he's not showing the collar.
I think there's a reason there are other like negative reinforcement
callers you can get that aren't just shock callers,
I wouldn't be shocked if it's one of those. I think there's like
hypersonic ones, there's vibration ones, there's ones that like
Yeah, it doesn't necessarily have to be a shock collar. It could
be something more humane. Oh, you guys showed XQC the green light.
He was able to find it. Okay. Oh, you don't got to defend him.
It's just a shock. I don't know why. Why would I just be so Why
Why would you want me to stop like looking for explanations for
this? Unless you're invested in some some specific answer more
than just knowing the truth.
Very strange. Very strange behavior from certain people in chat.
Very odd.
>> A baby.
>> Are you being fair to Hassan? Have you considered that?
Like there's no reason to just like try to figure out what's
happening here and you should just say Hassan is abusing his
dog. Have you thought about that?
>> No, I'm good. I'm good. >> Jesus Christ. What
are you doing? You're being such a baby. It's just
>> techone tweet from his vacation. First time dog owner
Techone will come out and tell us about how terrible this is.
Hold on. Wait, did you send that to me on Twitch? You did, bro.
I'm getting so many Twitch messages today as opposed to usual.
Usually the Twitch stream not bumping today. Twitch stream bumping.
Lots of links. >> Oh, Jesus Christ. See, this is this is
the actual See, Teto knows. Okay,
Teto knows that the actual thing here is not really going to
be the shock cuz shocking a dog is not even necessarily that
bad. shocking a dog just to keep it on stream and in frame that
starts to look way worse. Teone knows exactly how to narrativize
this to make us look the worst. He's basically directing people.
He's going, "You you want to make him look bad? Do this. He's
just doing it. This is Dumbo. Okay, this is He's just abusing
this dog to keep them on
That's that's the actual narrative you'd be thrown out. Also,
give me a sec. I got to reconnect my headphones.
Reconnecting.
reconnecting.
Oh, we're back. I started as soon as I saw that it cuts out sometimes
and as soon as it cut out, I like started um
making sound.
Heck. Oh, yeah. I see the new documents as well. I do see the
new documents as well in the Destiny case. So, we will probably
cover those because there's even bigger drama going on now. It's
probably an air tag and a shock collar. Maybe possible. Again,
that is some kind of like electrical or sorry, battery powered
collar of some kind. Okay, it's battery colored uh collar battery
powered collar of some kind. I It seems like the other ones we
find
are also shock collars. Like to get a battery powered GPS collar,
you also get like the shock feature put in or
Air tag and a digital fence collar.
Maybe yes, this dog goes outside all the time. Oo, coupling up
on GPS. I mean, unfortunately for him, the shot color thing is
going to be the most likely, and I don't think he's ever going
to deal with the fact that people are going to run with this.
I think he he does this thing where he like doesn't care about
it or something. And it's like, dude, you should care about it.
You should care about it. Why is this not loading? Could you
could you load, bro? I can't believe you're making her stressed.
I I She just literally is is >> so incredibly spoiled from
my mom. No, she doesn't want to come over here to see what's
up. She just wants to roam the house because she got to roam
the house when I was gone.
>> Chat has no way of understanding that this dog is better
taken care of than 99.9% of dogs on the planet given it that
its proximity to her owner is literally all day every day. And
also on top of that, dogs literally need time to themselves in
general in order to develop better like uh separation anxiety
like not have separation anxiety and not >> this is not
a good experience. >> Even better than dogs. She better
take care of the 99%.
>> Dogs need time to themselves to not develop separation
anxiety. This dog's around me 24/7. It's just just a weird thing
to throw out there. >> Like, what do you mean? Like human
chat >> Uh LSF LSF fell off. Yes, it fell off quite hard.
Here's an older clip. We watched the older clip where he says
he owns a shot collar where he says he has it. Um if you believe
that this guy being like a millionaire carried the same shot
collar across like multiple places, I just don't believe it.
I don't believe he would keep that.
Um, and also there's just no, it's like sort of meaningless because
I don't know if he'd keep it, but also he's literally probably
got a personal assistant that could just go buy him a shot caller
if he ever wanted one. So like whether or not he had it before,
it just doesn't make a difference to me. This was the drama around
how expensive the dog was when he initially bought it. Okay,
let's pull this pull this up. I'm going to close some of these
tabs. Close some of these tabs out real quick.
Is this going to play? Oh, it is going to incredible guardian
breeds on the
>> Zan realizes he's accidentally adopted the most expensive
dog breed in the >> One good look at these majorly imposing
dogs makes it easy to understand why they are the most expensive
dog breed in the world. With their long, shaggy manes, these
guys really do look like >> Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Okay. I
I'm sure there's going to be some more stuff that comes up out
of this. I really wish he had just shown the caller on stream.
I think we're going to move on in like
like 90 seconds. I'm going to check one one more time in LSF
looking for any other relevant or interesting commentary. Okay,
we'll take a quick look. We'll see if anything's there and then
if we can't find anything, we're going to move on to other stuff.
All right. All right. We will finally do it. We will finally
move on.
See, we got anything on a here. OH, WAIT. WHAT? Positive associated
Oh, no. Oh, hold on.
O totally just yked this from Oh, that's so gay. Why Why doesn't
he source best friend when he does this? This is so gay.
It's so uh It's so annoying that this guy just takes the video.
He just sources the video from best friend and doesn't like source
him, right?
Ah, it's so gross. >> In the same positive association
with Israel. So all this does is breed resentment
against Israel and also depending on howings in the same positive
assoc >> he's cooked he should be banned
I okay with Israel >> even in the worst case scenario even
in the absolute worst case scenario here for Hassan I don't think
this is something you ban him for I I don't think so again he
places the bed in in camera frame and it can look gross to people
but realistically forcing your dog to stay on the to be in the
room with you is not like abuse to the dog. That's not what it
is. That's not what it is. You're never going to convince me
of that. I think that's totally fine so long as he wants to keep
that dog on there and isn't using something like a shock collar
to do it.
There are different ways to train dogs. Yes. Yes, it is to keep
it on the bed with a shot collar. Yes.
The concept of keeping it on the bed is not a bad concept. That
is that is like not a bad concept at all. Why YMS has offered
to adopt a son's dog? No way.
Come on. Come on, man. It's weird. No, it's not. It's not weird.
It's not strange. It's not anything. It's literally totally fine.
All right. No, no, no. You could use coercion, but you should
be using like positive I'm telling you because it's like a dog
on stream, you shouldn't be using negative reinforcement to keep
it on that on that bed. You could like use some kind of positive
reinforcement to train it to stay on the bed, but if you're using
only negative reinforcement, you're making it look like it's
like scared as to get off the bed. It's not good. Right now,
Hassan is like absolutely just working on he's he's like texting
his assistants. They're going to find like some kind of collar
that that has the green light like that that they could put on
that dog and show tomorrow like, "Oh, no. It's not a shock collar
at all, guys. It's not. I I promise."
and then his fans are all going to be fine and everybody else
is going to assume that they switch the colors out. This is a
real issue by the way. It's not even >> that'll be what
it is. >> This is not even a
>> or not Paul Thomas Anderson. Sorry. I was thinking of
of um Edington Ari.
this is a real problem that directors have which is why in most
>> All right. >> In most movies, >> listen,
if he addresses it in some other way, we could go back to it
eventually. Okay. But there's there's other stuff for today and
I'm excited for the other stuff that we're going to cover today.
All right. All right, Ozel, you link me this Emily Yucas video.
I suspect this video will not be Twitch friendly. I would watch
it now if it could be considered Twitch friendly, but it is an
Emily Lucas video. So, if Ozel's still here, okay, let me know.
Let me know. Was there a green light on the collar? Yes, there
was a green light on the collar. Yes, the caller had a green
>> you see that? Do you see it? You go
boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom. That that collar has a green
light on it. It's some kind of battery powered collar. Okay.
Could be any collar. It could be something that's not a shock
collar, but it's a little weird that she probably has a shot
collar on. Although this video's got to be what, a year old.
I think this video's got to be nearly a year old
based on the uh based on the fur. I think the fur is a little
different,